my SmartWatch tracks how much sleep I
get each night if I'm feeling curious I
can look on my phone and see my nightly
Slumber plotted on a graph it might look
something like this and on the graph on
the y-axis we have the hours
of sleep and then on the x-axis we have
days
and this is an example
of a Time series
and what a Time series is
is data of the same entity like my sleep
hours collected at regular intervals
like over days and when we have time
series we can perform a Time series
analysis
and this is where we analyze the
timestamp data to extract meaningful
insights and predictions
about the future
and while it's super useful to forecast
that I'm going to probably get like
seven hours shut eye tonight based on
the data time series analysis plays a
significant role in helping
organizations drive a Better Business
decisions so for example using time
series analysis a retailer can use this
functionality to predict future sales
and optimize their inventory levels
conversely if you're into purchasing a
purchaser can use time series analysis
to predict commodity prices and make
informed purchasing decisions and then
in fields like agriculture we can use
time series analysis to predict weather
patterns influencing decisions on
harvesting and when to plant
so let's first of all introduce number
one
the components
of Time series analysis and then number
two we're going to take a look at some
of the
forecasting models
for performing time series analysis and
then number three we're going to talk
about how to implement
some of this stuff
okay now let's talk about the components
first of all and one component is called
trend
now this component refers to the overall
direction of the data over time whether
it's increasing whether it's decreasing
perhaps it's staying the same so you can
think of it like a line on the graph
that's either going up or going down or
staying flat
that's the first component the second
one
seasonality
now this component is a repeating
pattern of data over a set period of
time like the way that retail sales
Spike during the holiday season so we
might see a spike and then a bit lower
the spike is back and it keeps repeating
like that that's seasonality
third component
that's cycle
and cycle refers to repeating but
non-seasonal patterns in the data so
these might be economic booms and busts
that happen over several years or maybe
even decades so it's a much smoother
curve
and then lastly there is variation
and variation refers to the
unpredictable ups and downs in the data
that cannot be explained by these other
components and this component is also
known as irregularity or noise and well
it looks like maybe that
yeah very difficult to pick out the
trend
so those are some of the components of
Time series but let's talk about the
forecasting models that we can use to
perform some analysis and there are
several popular forecasting models out
there one of the most well known is
called the
arima model
now arima that stands for auto
regressive integrated moving average and
the model is made up of three components
so there's the the AR part that's the
auto regressive component and that looks
at how past values affect future values
then there's the I for
integrated or differencing components
and that accounts for Trends and
seasonality and then there is the m a
component that's the moving average
component and that Smooths out the Noise
by removing non-deterministic or random
movements from a Time series
so that's arima another pretty popular
one you'll often see is called
exponential smoothing
and exponential smoothings model is is
used to forecast time series data that
doesn't have a clear Trend or
seasonality so it doesn't fit into these
kind of areas and this model works by
smoothing out the data by giving more
weight to recent values and less weight
to older values and there are many other
forecasting models out there and the
right one to use of course depends on
the data you're working with and the
specific problem you're trying to solve
okay so that's finally talk a little bit
about implementation how do we implement
this there are several software packages
out there that can help you perform time
series analysis and forecasting such as
those with r and Python and Matlab
so if we just focus in on on python
for a moment
two of the most popular libraries for
time series analysis in Python
firstly pandas
and secondly
a library called mat plot
lied
with pandas you can easily import
manipulate and analyze the time series
data and it can handle things like
missing values aggregate data and
perform statistical analysis on the data
Matt plot live is a library that can
help you visualize the time series data
you can create line charts or Scatter
Plots and heat Maps using these
libraries you can perform a wide range
of Time series analysis tasks like data
cleaning exploratory data analysis and
modeling you can use pandas to
pre-process your time series data and
then use mat plus live to visualize the
trends and seasonalities in that data
look by understanding the components of
a Time series and then choosing the
right forecasting model you can make
more informed decisions and gain a
competitive Advantage so look whether
you're a data analyst or a business
owner or just a curious sleeper take
advantage of the power of Time series
analysis and get a glimpse into what the
future may hold
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching